so i'm not gonna lie up until a week or
so ago i was totally slacking on winter
2021 anime
i've only really been keeping up to date
with sequels like attack on titan and dr
stone and re-zero which
the last one i'm not even caught up on
anymore but i decided after checking out
mushoku tensei
to keep expanding because i mean it was
incredible
i mean honestly after watching redo of
healer as one of the first shows of this
season
i feel like most people would be
discouraged to keep watching anime like
[Music]
and i found wonder egg priority which i
also had heard great things about
and so i went into watching it yesterday
with no knowledge of what it was about
at all other than that
it was good and wow
along with mushoku tensei it has truly
impressed me and given me hope for a
really great year of anime after
you know the pretty boring year of anime
that was 2020
wonder egg priority is incredibly
insightful into the human psyche
specifically considering suicide an
incredibly prominent issue in japan to
this day
in october of last year more people died
from suicide in japan than from kovid
for the entirety of 2020
surging to a monthly high that hasn't
been seen in the country since
2015. it's a very sensitive topic
one that anime aren't necessarily shy to
touch upon
but it's rarely seen in such a prominent
manner as it is in wonder a priority
with its entire plot essentially
revolving around the suicide of young
girls
but wondered priority deals with these
issues in a very touching
and interesting and entertaining way one
that reminds me a lot of the iconic
puella magi madoka magica series from
2011.
i probably butchered that mano sorry if
you aren't watching one drink priority i
suggest you start soon as the season is
coming to a close
it's truly one of the more unique and
standout shows i've seen recently
something that i wouldn't say lightly
and today i'm going to talk about what
it's all about and why i
honestly love it also if you're part of
that 95
of my viewers who watch my videos but
aren't subbed yet make sure to subscribe
join us here at the anime culture corner
you won't regret it let's go
the story follows a young girl ai oto
who's been bullied and alienated her
whole life because she has heterochromia
a genetic condition where your eyes are
two different colors
which i honestly think is pretty sick
but i don't know
and after her best and only friend koito
commits suicide
oto loses touch with reality and is
enticed into purchasing an egg from a
mysterious entity
a wonder egg upon cracking this egg in
her dreams
oto is transported to a world where she
must save other girls from monsters
or rather their own demons the girls who
hatch from a wonder egg have all
committed suicide
and alto must help them overcome the
monsters that tormented them
in their life the reason and
manifestation for their suffering
and eventual suicide and by saving girls
like this oto is rewarded slowly by the
chance to save koito and get her best
friend back
but it's not so simple as just a dream
in fact while injuries regenerate
quickly in the dream as they fight off
these monsters these embodiments of
trauma
any wound they suffer there still exists
once they enter the real world again
it's essentially the same as a human if
they had no pain sensors
you can keep going sure but if you don't
recognize the damage to your body before
it's too late then you might end up past
the point of no return
and it also brings up the constant
question of how far odo is willing to go
to save her friend is she willing to
hurt herself
day in and day out to save her is she
willing to die for this
but most of all does coito even want
this
one of the most significant
philosophical questions that wonder egg
priority poses is whether buying wonder
eggs saving these girls
is truly to save the girls who kill
themselves or whether it's to save
yourself
a selfish act meant to just relieve you
of the guilt of letting your friend die
even if they themselves wanted to end it
all and wouldn't even want to come back
it's terrible to think about and wonder
egg priority touches upon it masterfully
there are so many great parts about
wondering priority but surely one of the
best to me was the dynamic between the
four main character girls
all of whom are trying to save someone
they lost through wonder eggs
and though they all use the same method
through wonder eggs none of them
have the same exact reason or origins or
relationship to the person who they're
trying to save
essentially everyone has their own
distinct trauma
as we get deeper into the show we follow
each of them individually through the
loss that drove them to become
wonder egg girls i'll call them and all
four of them are super interesting all
of them are fleshed out to great depths
and as they enter these worlds and try
to save these girls from their monsters
they have to combat their own issues at
the same time
they can even be tempted by these inner
demons of other girls
as they're all very human problems being
molested
abuse bullied these are all issues that
wonder egg priority faces that manifest
in these dreams and that the girls have
to fight
and there's also a sense of mystery to
the show that keeps the plot moving
what are wonder eggs why do they exist
but also we unravel koito's story a
suicide that isn't so simple as just
bullying
otto wants to understand why her best
friend wouldn't confide in her and took
her life instead
and through this story we explore her
guilt and mistakes and oh my god i just
love it
i know i was gushing about mushoku
tensei a couple days ago but for me
wonder egg priority has become more of a
personal favorite
as a mushishi and stein's gate and
monogatari series lover you can kind of
tell my tastes
the dark intense philosophical
questioning it's
it's right up my alley the animation is
impeccable there's never a weak moment
and the style goes well with the very
colorful tones used
just like puella magi madoka magika
which i mentioned earlier
it subverts your expectations with the
very colorful and playful exterior that
covers the dark discussions beneath the
surface
if you haven't seen puella magi madoka
magica it has a similar concept
of a number of girls finding a magical
mysterious entity who offers them power
to fulfill their dreams but of course as
i said it is way darker than it first
and it's one of if not the most
prominent anime within the magical girl
genre to do this
back in 2011 i highly recommend it
especially if you're enjoying wondering
priority it's a great show
the ost is also great it's got like this
really cute ambient music when the girls
are together and very smoothly switches
into
electronic action music when they begin
fighting or enter a dream
it helps to create this really cool
contrast between the dream world and the
real world
both of which are tainted with trauma
and sadness unfortunately
which i think the show also wants to
emphasize that there is no escape to
your problems
in your dreams or in death instead you
must deal with them
or just learn to live with it suicide is
one of the saddest things that can
happen to someone you know
and love and wondering priority doesn't
fail to discuss it in a really creative
and
interesting way
and that's it for me you've gotta watch
wondering priority it truly amazed me
and i cannot wait to see how this season
finishes
it's setting a great start to 2021 along
with michoku tensei of course
it's really exciting stuff
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
comment what you think down below don't
forget to like and subscribe for future
in-depth show
manga and character analyses
you